close your eyes that way you can't be
tempted
before ginny there was cho and hermione
or
was it always ginny while the movies
didn't do jenny justice
if we consider the character from the
books then there's a much stronger
argument for why
ginny was the one for harry from
consistently being by his side to
sharing a significant passion to one
extremely unique link that connected
them to each other on a level that no
one else could
let's take a look at why exactly ginny
was harry's soul mate
first of all ginny's loyalty to harry is
no small thing
while she wasn't as present early on in
the series the youngest weasley had eyes
for harry from the get-go
sure she was a bit overcome by the
notoriety of the boy who lived but
what wizard wouldn't be he is a legend
after all
to harry she started out as the younger
sister of his best friend
but really it was always a bit more than
that since the weasleys quickly became
like family for potter
let's not forget that the two also share
a very unique and special connection
both of them had experienced being
possessed by voldemort
it's inevitable that they have a special
bond through that
remember when harry missed sirius and
longed for a way to speak to him
even though it was dangerous the one
person who understood and worked to help
him find a way to communicate with him
was ginny
that is a true companion fast forward to
later in the series when harry had eyes
for cho chang
let's be honest this probably wasn't a
fun thing for jenny to witness but
it didn't stop her from being harry's
friend she supported him even though he
didn't choose her
it's important to consider the fact that
she not only supported his relationship
but
all the ventures and struggles he faced
at the same time
we can't forget that she was an integral
part of dumbledore's army
while she wasn't literally next to
harry's side when he was away battling
voldemort
she carried on his legacy within
hogwarts leading all the students who
were part of the army
that's exactly where she needed to be
and through her role she remained a
constant companion for harry
she supported the legacy and was a
leader for the wizarding community as a
whole
could harry have asked for a better
friend their unwavering friendship was a
major part of leading the way towards
their romantic relationship
don't you trust me
now that we've covered how loyal jenny
was to harry let's not forget the fact
that she was also a strong and
independent woman who didn't need
harry's affections to be the amazing
wizard she was
she's an unbelievable witch all on her
own remember all her brilliant bat bogey
hexes
slughorn even selected her to be part of
the prestigious slug club it's weasley
come in
come in anyone who saw her in action
knew she was someone special
we still get chills thinking about her
beautiful patronus charm and how quickly
she caught on to so much
not only that but she was also a great
and supportive teacher to others
when it comes to her independence with
regard to harry well
let's not forget that when he broke up
with her she took it in stride and
revealed that was part of the reason she
probably loved him
she knew there were things more
important than their relationship that
they were both meant to do
harry had a mission and ginny understood
that they both had their own work to
fulfill
harry needed to go after baltimore ginny
had to support and lead her community at
hogwarts
if their relationship was meant to be it
would happen when the time was right
the sense of responsibility the two of
them shared for the safety of their
loved ones was strong and definitely
contributed to the strength of their
relationship in the end you have to get
rid of it
today while ginny did adore and care
deeply for harry she
also wasn't afraid to stand up to him
and tell him what was what
remember when she called him out for not
remembering that she too had been
possessed by voldemort
she wasn't about to stand by his
lamenting and let him believe he'd been
the only one who dealt with that
hardship
no she made sure to let him know how it
was
and reminded him of the reality they all
faced she didn't just say what he wanted
to hear she was strong enough to stand
up to him and therefore help him
actually grow and think with other
perspectives in mind
take my hand if it weren't for ginny
harry probably would have had a much
harder time getting past his emotions
and recognizing the bigger picture
not to mention the fact that she was
always able to make him laugh
a definite necessity to get through all
those hardships while she did
sort of worship him when she was young
can we really blame her
she was just a little girl but as she
got older she could better understand
that the boy who lived was a miracle
yes but he was also just human
she didn't place him on a pedestal
despite her strong feelings
she was independent enough to recognize
that he was flawed in his own ways and
needed others to help him
just like anyone else tough strong
level-headed and optimistic
to quote the fiery redhead herself
anything's possible if you've got enough
nerve
need we say more merry christmas sorry
now that we've laid out all the reasons
that ginny is pretty much one of the
best characters from the whole harry
potter series
we have to consider some of the other
great characters that could have stolen
harry's heart
yes cho chang and of course hermione
granger
both really wonderful women but why was
ginny the better fit for harry
well first off the two of them had one
very important passion in common
quidditch sure cho also played quidditch
but the spore was significant to harry
and ginny on a different level
not to mention they were both standout
players while we're talking about
harry's relationship with cho
let's be honest at the end of the day it
was just a bit
too complicated even if the two of them
had stayed together
cho's relationship with harry would
always remain tied to her relationship
with cedric
a heartbreak that she needed much more
time to move on from
it's hard to believe they could have
looked past that heartbreak and not
worried about it coming up as an issue
somewhere down the line
the loss of cedric was devastating for
them both and while they could
definitely support each other as friends
a relationship probably wasn't the best
route to take
you're a really good teacher harry as
for hermione
ron was just the better fit for her the
two of them were very different but
balanced each other out in a really
beautiful way while they may have seemed
like an unlikely pair
it was a case of opposites attract for
them and who was harry to get in the way
of that
no the two of them were his best friends
he of course wanted what was best for
them both
with cho the relationship would have
been underscored with too much sadness
with hermione the relationship probably
would have struggled with being too
serious
whereas with ginny harry could
experience a lightness in his life
throughout the series ginny could always
make him laugh they shared a sense of
dark humor and
a longing for a moment of escape when
the two of them were together
it was sometimes like they were in their
own little world
it was simple and good something they
both
definitely needed with all they'd faced
in their lives not to mention harry and
ginny getting married and building a
family together was a fairly natural
move
since harry was very much part of the
weasley family already
the weasley clan felt like home for
harry so when they became his in-laws
it probably wasn't a tough transition at
all the family he'd always longed for
was there for him
and would be for life making it official
with his marriage to ginny was just
meant to be
while we could say cho and hermione
could have changed that considering all
the factors
it seems to us that there was only ever
ginny
thanks all right um looking at all the
evidence
it's obvious why the boy who lived found
his love in the youngest weasley
looking at their lives together for them
to become family just made sense
they always had been and while harry
potter is the
harry potter let's be honest ginny is a
total catch
you